what's up folks I'm multiple Navy AK and
it's time for another 90s edition of top
5 you've seen me count down the top 5
best and worst Mighty Morphin Power
Ranger episodes the top 5 best 90
Cartoon Network shows the top 5 best 90s
mixes and today were keeping it orange
for the top 5 best Rob I hear you still
perpetuating nineties propaganda sake
you can try welcome to the jam
these are the top 5 best 90s Nickelodeon
shows if you had cable in the 90s
Nickelodeon was a one-stop destination
for endless hours of kids entertainment
besides those classic animated Nicktoons
Nickelodeon had plenty of live-action
programs that have sex with us 90s kids
to the state I want to say right off the
bat that we're not counting the awesome
game shows that Nick had out during that
era they deserve and are getting their
own list in the near future well they're
scaring us making us laugh or
occasionally teaching us a very
important life lesson this channel had
it all for children of the 90s what made
these show stick out were how unique and
sometimes straight-up weird they were
however Nickelodeon taught us to embrace
that weirdness there's a special take on
kids programming that made a ton of
these shows very memorable and today
we're counting down the very best one
Nick Nick Nick Nick Nick Nick Nick I
love ya number five
[Music]
Melissa Joan Hart was a teen idol in the
90s and while most people know her as
Sabrina the Teenage Witch it all started
here with her explaining it all as
Clarissa Marie darling Clarissa lives
with her parents and brother Ferguson
while trying to navigate life as a
teenage girl she always directly
addresses the audience to describe
what's happening in each episode and
usually dresses in a style all her own
without its star Clarissa explains it
all probably wouldn't have been as
successful as it was it was the perfect
marriage of tone and heart herself her
charisma and relatability transcended
just one gender both girls and boys were
fans of the show during and after his
run we all know Clarissa's brother
Ferguson was her main adversary on the
show if you grew up with siblings at one
point or another you probably thought
they acted a little like Ferguson which
this is a night her best friend Sam was
always reliable if for nothing else at
least that music cue that played
whenever he showed up at Clarissa's high
now hail Orson Clarissa was a fun and
original character she did her own thing
and the kids who grew up watching loved
her for it my favorite thing about the
show though gotta be the theme song I
[Music]
wonder
number four swept out the clock look at
what's ready yet get set it's all
[Music]
this was a trademark Nickelodeon show
they didn't call it the 90s or all that
for nothing all that was pretty much
Saturday Night Live for kids every
episode would feature a set of mostly
reoccurring sketches with characters as
zany as the time period they were made
in one of the main bits was even turned
into a movie you remember that one don't
you welcome to good burger home of the
good burger can I take your order in a
lot of ways this was the cornerstone of
90s Nickelodeon it created stars like
can tell and Amanda Bynes while also
creating characters that are as
memorable as anything on the network at
the time who doesn't remember coach
creep what goes up must come down let me
go oh my god super dude that's right I'm
super dude the teenage superhero with
powers far beyond those of hit it's like
this guy with the plunger on his face
Lori Beth Denberg with vital information
for your everyday life it's rude to talk
with your mouth full
it's even ruder to blow your nose and
your sisters pinch repair a man and even
[Music]
my ears aren't even that big number
three submitted for the approval of the
midnight society yep this show scared
the crap out of an entire generation
even you don't deny it are you afraid of
the dark revolved around a group of
teenagers called the midnight society
who every week would meet up in the
middle of the woods and exchange scary
stories as the audience who would be
able to see these stories play out while
they were told on the show every week
was a new spooky tale and the only thing
to carry over was the midnight society
them so this show definitely pushed some
limits back in the day and a portion of
these episodes are still pretty creepy
the mood was always set perfectly with
that chilling intro
[Music]
of course this show always gets compared
to goosebumps debates with your friends
about the scarier show could rage on for
days there are too many great episodes
to mention here but does anyone remember
the faceless aliens episode because my
nightmares still do what's she talking
about
this is joke of what Tamra hi number two
[Music]
The Adventures of Pete and Pete was a
strange show but I wouldn't have had it
any other way this show filed two
brothers both named Pete and their
exploits in their home town big Pete is
the narrator of the show and often a
more normal character compared to the
eccentric people and situations that
surround him little Pete is just about
as rebellious as they come in addition
to frequently defying the authority
figures he comes in contact with he has
a tattoo on his arm named petunia and an
adult friend named Artie who is the
self-proclaimed drug offender in the
world
you may recognize big Pete Mike Maronna
from home alone and little Pete Danny
tamborelli from all that and figure it
out he became a staple of the network
after the show
Pete Pete still has a very strong cult
following it's ranked on many lists as
one of the best written kid shows ever
while its two stars are close to this
day and even hosts a podcast together
called The Adventures of Danny and Mike
the band who played the theme song
Polaris was in Chicago a couple years
ago and wouldn't you know it Danny and
Mike were at the concert they recorded
an episode of their podcast before the
show and Danny even went on stage to jam
out to Pete and Pete Shane the point of
all that being this show really
resonated with the kids who grew up with
it as an adult it's still as watchable
as ever with new things to pick up on
I'd encourage you to go back and watch a
few episodes on a network filled with
unique programs at the time this one
stood out
[Music]
[Applause]
Nickelodeon was in no short supply of
great shows in the 90s so before we get
to number one here are some honorable
mentions
[Music]
and the number one best 90s Nickelodeon
show is all right look when I was we
watching these old shows and I saw how
well are you for the dark held up and
how good PTIN pizza was I thought to
myself there's no way that my old
favorite Kingdom Kell can still be
number one but then I watched Nalepa
sold and it R is given Kell wins I can't
fight my heart man i can't do i do tapas
guru finger to their kenan and kel was a
sitcom starring all that cast members
Kenan Thompson and Kel Mitchell they
followed their misadventures in Chicago
as the pair of best friends went to high
school and got involved in all types of
hijinks Kenan was the schemer and
straight man of the duo while Kel was
his wacky comedic foil who also loved
orange soda who loves o exo-k loves
orange soda is it true is it true oh yes
oh yes yes it's true
Kenan & Kel worked so well together that
their names are still intertwined with
each other 17 years after the show ended
with Kenan continuing his sketch comedy
on Saturday Night Live it's good to
still see an icon of the 90s doing such
big things Kel has popped back up in
recent years on the network that gave
him his start last year some of the
original cast of all that reunited for a
Q&A and to discuss the show which
included both Kenan and Kel
what's the one question you're asked
most often I did wear - Oh most
definitely I get where it says where's
your body answers that's the question
everybody got let's go let's go yeah I
don't know here we'll always love this
show for it's crazy plot lines and
slapstick humor Kenan & Kel still give
me a good laugh to this day Nickelodeon
will remain in our 90s hearts forever
these shows shaped how a lot of us view
the world early on
reflected authentic experiences back at
us even if they were through a funhouse
mirror sometimes make sure to be on the
lookout for the top 5 best 90s
Nickelodeon game shows coming later this
year we want to hear what you guys think
what is your favorite 90s Nickelodeon
show leave a comment down below and let
us know you can follow me on twitter at
camera l chambers for more content
subscribe to my personal channel
youtube.com slash awesome walter also
like my new facebook page facebook.com
slash awesome alter b and follow me on
twitter to take part in more polls about
what may be covered in the future that
reminds me
tammer grab a fire extinguisher a pencil
sharpener a triceratops wallet an
elephant urine and maybe i Doug's house
at midnight what Walter what's the
pencil sharpener for Walter Walter oh
here he goes
[Music]
you